- Today we're gonna talk
about the dos and don'ts
of your first week in law school.
And I know you're
freaking out, that's okay,
don't worry about it because none of this
is going to be on the test.
(short jingle)
The first week of law school can seem
completely overwhelming.
Just take a step back and realize
that it's all going to be okay.
Everyone feels overwhelmed.
You're thrown into a situation
that you've never been in before.
You're learning about subjects
that you didn't know existed.
It's probably going over your head.
You probably feel stressed out,
you might be a little freaked out,
that's okay, everyone feels that way.
But let's talk about
all the dos and don'ts
of your first week of law school.
Everything you can do
to maximize your chances
of success later on and
everything you can do
to minimize your stress in the present.
You should understand that
the way that law school
is taught is completely backwards.
You learn the most antiquated arcane cases
early on in the semester and
there is very little chance
that any of those cases will
be used on the final exam.
For example, if you are in Property
you might learn about Pierson versus Post
which is the case where
two men pursued a fox
but one man killed it and carried it away,
and it's a dispute about who
had possession of the fox.
And the rule of law is that
mere pursuit of the animal
itself does not give you a right to the
ownership of the animal.
But guess what, there are
almost no exams in the history
of Property where citing
to Pierson versus Post
is a way to get points on the final exam.
It's weird because, strangely enough,
pursuing animals is not
something that is often done
in modern society, and
therefore those situations
just don't come up that much.
So don't worry that every
single class seems to start
with these antiquated
cases that will not be
on your final exam and really
don't do much to further
your understanding of the substantive law.
So don't feel bad if you
feel completely overwhelmed
with the arcane law from the
Court of Exchequer in England,
it's a way to ease into
the semester and it's not
information that you're going to be
responsible for later on.
The second thing to realize is that
a lot of the information that your school
is going to give you is bad.
For example, I know that in UVA
the professors give over an
hour lecture on case briefing,
how to highlight the
procedural posture of a case,
how to separate out all the
different parts of a case.
That information is completely useless.
Case briefs are just a waste of time
and the information, it
comes from a good place,
they want to give you some idea of what
you should be doing, but it
really just fosters busy work.
So don't feel bad if the
information that you're given
in orientation or the advice
that you got before law school
is contradictory or it
seems like it's creating
more busy work than it
seems like the benefit
that you're getting out of it.
It's probably the case,
you're going to get
contradictory advice.
And unless it's coming from
us it's probably bad advice.
So don't feel like you
have to do everything
that you were told before
going into law school
and don't assume that just
because your law school
tells you to do something
you should be doing it.
Often it's the absolute
opposite of that case.
With respect to case briefs,
I see professors giving the
advice that all students
should case brief every
case that they get.
I think that's really terrible advice,
in fact we have an entire video
on why case briefing is bad
and why you shouldn't do it.
If you feel you must case brief,
do it once and then put it aside.
I know the final exam might
seem like it's a long way off,
but take a look at an issue spotting exam
and see if there is any
way that you can imagine
that you can use the
information of case brief
in the final exam.
Odds are you can't, and I've
been doing this for a while,
I've never seen a case where
using all of the information
in a case brief actually
helped on the final exam,
I think it's just busy
work, it's a waste of time.
Next, you're gonna meet a lot of people.
Think about forming a study group,
but don't put a lot of
pressure on yourself.
Study groups can be great,
they're not always necessary,
some people learn better in groups,
some people will feel like
they waste a lot of time
just going on in endless
conversation in study groups.
Feel it out, perhaps
start up a study group,
but don't feel bad if
you don't want to join
study groups or if you
feel like the study groups
are passing you by.
Don't over commit.
Now is the time to try things out.
I know it feels like everything
is coming down on you
and you're overwhelmed and slammed,
but really, you'll be able to separate
what's working for you and
what's not in the weeks to come.
In that vein, don't try to do everything.
Know that there's a limited
amount of time that you have
and you'll want to really
maximize the things that give you
high return on investment,
things like outlining,
things like practice exams,
things like distilling
and synthesizing your notes
with commercial supplements.
But don't try and do
absolutely everything.
Don't try to join every extracurricular
and don't join every single
intramural sports team.
There is time for some of that stuff
but don't feel like you
need to try everything out.
At the end of your first
week, what I would recommend
is start outlining.
Over the weekend what I liked
to do during my semester
was use your weekends for outlining.
Distill all of your notes with all of your
supplementary material.
Your weekends are your time.
While during the week
you're going to class,
you're preparing for class,
carve out your weekends
to start outlining.
And if you outline every single week
by the time the study period
rolls around and finals,
you'll be studying from your outline
while everybody else is starting
to put together their outline.
Now, sure, there's value in
putting your outline together,
but there's far more value in
getting that out of the way
so you can study from it and
start using practice tests.
And remember, even though it's week one
you want to think about the endgame.
It's all about finals.
It's very rare that class participation
counts for anything.
So remember to always focus on the things
that are going to provide
value at the final.
It's never too early to
make that realization.
And understand that it's
almost all about essays.
Even in classes that have
some multiple choice questions
the majority of your points
are gonna come from essays.
And in most first year classes
almost all of the points
come from issue spotting
long form essays.
And now is a good time to
think about the strategies
that go towards better essay writing
because a lot of your points and a lot
of your final grade is gonna be based
on an issue spotting exam.
Because so many professors
use issue spotting exams
you can use the same
strategies in every class
regardless of the substantive law.
Legal Eagle offers an entire
class on mastering issue
spotting exams, and
there are others as well
that are also very good.
But it's never too soon
to realize that most of
your grade is going to come
from issue spotting exams.
So the bottom line is, it's
week one, but don't freak out.
You're gonna have the
entire rest of the semester
to get into your groove.
Everybody starts out in feeling like
a stranger in a foreign land.
Very little of what you're
learning in your first week
is going to be on the test, so you can try
different methodologies
of preparing for class
and working on your outline.
You can find what works for you,
and then really get
into your groove for the
rest of the semester.
I know it can seem
completely overwhelming,
but that's okay, it happens to everyone.
Now is a great time to take a deep breath,
realize that it's all going to be okay,
and think about the habits
that will get you across
the goal line at the end of the semester.
If you liked this video please
click Like and subscribe
for more law school crushing tips.
And also click below to
download the free checklist
to help crush law school.
So, thanks.
Thanks for stopping by.
(lively music)